what's your number to have an x-rated
only fans account
[Music]
hey guys i'm alex i'm jordan and we are
here to answer the internet also august
19th tomorrow by rnr.com i'm going to
kick cupcake's ass
no kicking no kicking oh yeah just just
okay if you had a threesome with one
female actor who would be feeling sidney
sweeney yes margot robbie oh
that's exactly that's like margaret
margaret yeah for sure yeah i love her
voice on woken wall street though marco
robbie's voice like
yeah that's what i love daddy yeah yeah
you're awesome yeah okay for the rest of
your life would you rather have regular
sex oral sex or anal sex
definitely not anal okay so not anal so
oral or regular
surprise you the one that
are struggling with this well i'm just
trying to think like all the like fun
things you can do of either way no i
just don't like to 69 is a big
difference that's very true i thought
about that and stopped asking the
questions like because think about it
you can do regular sex yourself like you
can buy things for that but oral you
can't buy anything to do that you know
what i mean yeah and like they always
can like stick stuff in you correct so
maybe oral the rest of my life and then
we can just buy things that take place
of the disc it's never the same it is it
is regular
i mean i've been single for a long time
so yeah that's that's okay i'm going
regular for sure overall is jerking off
to webcam girls cheating oh we just
talked about this in our last episode
perfect plug go download it
would it be if graham did it yes
yeah if you're in a relationship yes
it's cheating is it live that's what i'm
wondering because is the girl live or is
it like a pre-recorded no i yeah webcam
girls are live oh then yes it's cheating
yeah what about if it's live but there's
not there's no like they're not
interacting like it's live for like a
ton of people if it's not the person
you're married to i think you're i think
it's cheating if it's if it's la
anything live yes pre-recorded different
story but live why is that i don't know
something about it being live just kind
of makes it seem more intimate seems
emotional either way yeah i think what
about
if it's live
but someone else is like doing the
interacting with her but he's just like
jerking off to that he doesn't talk to
her he doesn't tell her what to do
someone else is doing all that cheating
that's what a porn is i don't really
think it's cheating i just think it's
like the same thing as a problem it'd be
an issue
all right what about now i'm gonna [ __ ]
you guys now you're done okay what about
if you watched
uh like a live stream of someone on a
porn set making a movie and jacked off
to it yeah yeah cheating that's cheating
i watched a live stream of a porn
film shoot i'm i'm liberal on a lot of
thoughts this is the one that i'm not on
no i don't think it's cheating but i
would have an issue with it for sure
we'd have to have a conversation
immediately just like cameras in a setup
what's his why is he doing it huh why is
he doing it like am i not satisfied live
stream of it like hey we're live
streaming our shoot today
to be in the room with him yeah this
will do
we're down to do the job
okay you can only have one
oh god i hate these questions only one
okay six inches
oh god okay six feet
six figures six feet
because remember we don't need the six
inch dick and i at this point i'm making
six figures now so it's fine
with only fans i'm good to go it's fine
there it is
i'm just like my life is just changing
yes
well it hasn't been my account yet i
have a dream list of things i'm going to
buy and i told alex
i want to go to napa and sonoma she did
she's adding napa and sonoma we're going
to the hamptons on a blade we were going
to we were going to take the train she's
like can we blade and i'm like let's
play girl
do it i'm
this is a loaded question okay who would
win in a fight kirk minihan or chris
climber
did you just make that up no it's it's
written on the card oh i was like wow
that was that's timely oh chris chris
for sure
kirk isn't actually i'm not gonna say
anything mean about kirk i don't want
him to come for me jordan earlier who's
kirk i don't know who kirk is i just
know he was as crazy as he is
chris
glimmer isn't kirk pretty little because
clemmer's my teammate now it's like you
like once you're with them and once the
other one goes against you you just take
them like that's just your that's just
your answer and whatever her team is in
my team so
is it weird for a guy to prefer lube
hand jobs over blow jobs no i don't
think so you should always be using lube
with the hand job though so
so like rip their skin off it's just
like a girl being like i want to be
fingered versus eating out yeah and and
he might know that you're bad at
[ __ ] so he might prefer your hand i
think that could be an option yeah but i
i would think a guy would prefer
a job yeah you would think i don't think
it's weird though but is it weird we
don't fetish or sex shame over here okay
no if you're in defeat that's fine would
you rather get proposed to at a baseball
game
or at a cracker barrel cracker barrel i
can't the idea of getting proposed in
public like that terrifies me if you're
proposing to me at a cracker barrel
we
we're gonna get divorced because some
somebody didn't understand what i was
looking for in my mind okay so at the
baseball game there's an opportunity
that maybe we're on the field afterwards
or in a suite or something
it's like the seventh inning stretch
like god i'm mad either way then yeah
if it's the seventh inning stretch and
i'm on the jumbotron it's cracker barrel
yeah
if it's a baseball player that's on the
field i'm at the baseball game yeah
don't propose to it yeah if you're a
professional athlete then let's lower
your talk this is options
i don't want married if you can make
your tits any size you want but knowing
that your boyfriend's chest has to be
the same size what size you're going for
that sucks because it's like either i
have to suffer no matter what looking at
him or i have to suffer because i would
have small even smaller boobs this is
when we we go sacrificial lamb and we go
small and let them stay small that's
what i'm doing 100 like how small though
regular size for a guy is 100 what i'm
doing there because i i think a small
chest could be made cool would i prefer
like c's yes but not i can't possibly
what good would c's do if he's walking
around with c's two like immediately
could possibly not do it because would
they be like like this saggy
in no scenario yeah okay would you
rather have bad sex for the rest of your
life or every time is like 50 shades of
grey that's hard because i've never
experienced the 50 shades of gray sex
because like i could love it for all i
know but i've never had it whoops and
chains type thing yeah maybe i probably
would have to go 50 shades because bad
sex would you have a sad life i think
i'm going to go 50 shades too and hope
we can make it work yeah hope maybe
he'll he won't whip the chain that hard
and you can make it a thing
yeah i mean you have to use whips
what's your number to have an x-rated
only fans account like a cost yeah
what's next never there's no cost
there's no price
the amount you can make with doing the
pg content that's just fine with me have
you thought about the amount you could
make okay let's do this let's do this
let's do this right now a million
dollars in your bank account if you do
an x-rated post yes or no okay five
million would you interesting show your
chance for a millionaire no i don't
think so not at this age maybe if i was
like if i had like a million kids and i
needed to like i was like dying but like
i don't need it right now you know it's
like
anybody who's on the internet
yeah and immediately a million dollars
hits it i i don't think so not because
because like since i love like this job
so much i don't think so but if i didn't
have a job and that's all i had like if
barclay's like you're fired you can
never get a job gonna be like fine okay
you know what i mean so no number yeah
you have to be in the scarcity mentality
or i would have to like take this sex
worker route to want to do that you need
to put food on the table yeah yeah and
then you're going to go big yeah then
you could then you could put food yeah
oh i'm not a very high number yeah
that's always been my thing now i'm like
yeah it's not that like
but i think it's like i also know i
wouldn't do it you know if you're
telling me that you're gonna
like a million dollars is going to be
transferred to me yeah
yeah i think i would yeah i would do
that
500 grand
no
750 no 800.
9.95 no i need that common really good
extra comma
would you rather be known as the girl
who has [ __ ] a hundred people or zero
people
like just known or actually haves no
that's just like your reputation oh zero
yeah yeah i thought you'd say that you
could like surprise them
i actually know check it out
zero yeah all day like who cares why
would you want to be the girl known as
100 yeah yeah you could have zero would
you rather never get your nails done
again or never get your hair done again
never eat my hair because this is my now
my natural color yeah and and for me
it's definitely nails because this is
not my natural color
can you imagine a life with no nails no
that's a sad life yeah it's been a sad
life yeah you're doing it well that was
because i didn't have the money you know
now
no now your tips
[Applause]
i woke up this morning i was like why
did i say that i'm going to tell you
anyone you won't have this morning
loaded i was like no
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon